ومعنا الان من ميدان جرافر بلندن مراسلنا
اسد الله اسعد الله الى اي مرحله وصلت
المراسم العام
[موسيقى]
جمهوريه هؤلاء يتظاهرون هنا منذ الصباح
وصف حشود كبيره من المؤيدين للملكيه
ويتعالى الهوتات يبدو ان الموكب يمر من
جانبنا الان هؤلاء مجموعه تم اعتقال سته
اشخاص منهم بمن فيهم رئيس المجموعه منذ
الصباح وتدخلت الشرطه اكثر من مره وقامت
حتى بنزع بعض الاعلام منهم يشار الى ان
هناك نوع من التوتر حدث ايضا بين اعضاء
هذه الجماعه جماعه او مجموعه
مؤيدين للملكيه وهم منتشرون باعداد اكبر
بكثير هنا مريم يجب الاشاره الى ان احد
استطلاعات الراي لوسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه حديثا اشار الى ان واحدا من كل
اربعه بريطانيين يؤيد تحويل البلاد الى
جمهوريه بدلا من
الملكيه انه